I'd say being in a blended family the
hardest part is the beginning it's war
it's emotional it's difficult you're
getting used to new people step families
are born of loss coming together and
making a blended family work and
crossing that divide into making it
successful is quite tricky so you've met
your partner you're really happy you're
moving on you may be moving in together
thing is going to be great or are they
don't expect it to be perfect
don't expect the children to love you
immediately the children have had losses
the children need to mourn what used to
be their family and things have changed
everything is sort of moving about and
shifting so give everybody time to do
that they will do so at their own pace
don't expect them to be where you are
with your partner recognizing it takes
probably four years as the average for a
step family to form so you know don't
rush things you know you might have been
together two or three years but you're
still on a journey you may go into the
step family as a step parent and assume
you're going to be something maybe it's
a surrogate mother maybe you want to be
the Bowness mother or maybe you want to
be nothing at all to those stepchildren
but also you're dealing with the
children's expectations of you if I ask
you what a mum is supposed to do or a
dad a biological mom or dad most people
have a great idea we all know but if I
ask the same people
what's a stepmom what's a stepdad I
probably get different answers my own
research found that that stepmoms have
significantly higher anxiety than
biological mums this confusion with role
not knowing what they were supposed to
do were they supposed to you know take
more control in the house where they
supposed to be more integrated with the
children leave the children to the
biological parent think about what
you're comfortable doing are you
comfortable spending more time with the
children the important thing is to talk
to your partner work out what role you
have in your family there are no rights
and wrongs but it is important that you
both agree
[Music]
with my stepsister it took about a year
until we started feeling like proper
family and I do consider her now like a
full sister and someone I can go to kind
of in a time of need
it probably has well took a year until
we started bickering like you do over
clothes and she's mainly and I think
that's when you can really tell that
you're starting to feel like a family
when you feel like you can just lose
your rag at someone if they or your crop
top debt families are often very busy
homes there can be children from both
partners there can be children from the
new partnership they may not all get on
again that's really common siblings
don't necessarily get on try finding
ways of engaging all the children so try
and develop something to do an activity
with each of the children so they can
feel special they can develop a
relationship with both their parent
their biological parent and also the
step parent so find a thing to do it
might be going out on a bike ride it
might be making cakes together whatever
works in your family each family member
will come into this new family with
different memories but you want to make
your own memories as a family so bring
everyone together and that should start
to bring everybody to feel a sense of
belonging
some of you might have heard the term
Disney dad it's a term that people use
where that the the biological dad sees
his kids perhaps at weekends or holidays
and he feels that he's got to make it
the best time ever
so his children are coming he's missed
firm and he just wants to make up for
the time when he's not with them it
could mean that that time becomes just
fun time and that's not real and it's
not sustainable don't let the children
be feeling that how many kind of dance
because of what he's going to give me
those any present we're going to go and
do something great that shouldn't be the
case it's fine to treat your children
but not all the time
when people ask me if I am upset about
my parents supporting I would say no
like never I'm so happy now my parents
are happy in respective relationships
and I gained a younger sister and two
older brothers and for me now having
that like that's worth you know maybe a
year or two of some quite hard times but
now I look back and I think well you
know that that's great I've gained all
of this so most stepfamilies
have this a period where they're trying
to sort of not be a step family if they
just want to blend in and it's not about
blending units about being who you are
enjoy it and you'll find you know as you
develop as you integrate you'll find
your own norm and your own happiness
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon